I have someone that's better than
Belichick yeah okay we're gonna jump
over the line jump over the line
[Music]
what up welcome to another episode of
Sims and left go but guess what just you
and me and your weird Star Trek shirt
we've got ourselves and also guessing
just kidding woody the shirts awesome
2-ball Adams best safety in the NFL yeah
I'll Presidente how you feeling then
feeling good man do you agree with me
that you're the best safety in the NFL I
do
no where is your level right now you
look around the league how confident are
you and why is it clicking so well I'm
just getting started man I'm just you
know scraping the surface as I called it
but you know I just want to continue to
get better each and every day
I'm working on the little dings just
trying to be the best at those things
obviously my interception numbers are
not highest oh no that's it within but
that's that's that's where you know
logistics are both the the world is kind
of going as far as who's the best but I
think that day man I'm I know what I'm
capable capable of doing yeah I know
what I can bring to the field and bring
to the team you guys share the
connection
your pops we do got a little connection
his dad George Adams like one of the guy
had a bad hip injury that really ruined
his career
but I know just from my dad's
perspective it was always George Adams
your father always comes up as one of
those guys of what if cuz I know he
thinks they played together they played
together yeah I mean he was on the 86
Super Bowl team Wow so you're telling me
that your dad his dad and mark Ingram's
dad we're all on the same team to go
crazy yeah I know and now here's this
generation right sorry the scrub and
then these two guys make something of
their lives you talk about humility
I'm sensing a trend that is the opposite
of that every interception every fumble
recovery I'm watching defenses run into
the end zone yeah and they're all
sitting there and they're posing a big
line and get in the back either like
this every game I see Wow yes what do
you think of the trend I hate it really
yeah because Hennessey and his crazy you
said that I really do hate it because
one thing it's the same thing
let the Saints do with the same you're
getting it to the Saints I think the
first for what I seen and what I what I
know right I think the Saints were the
first people to do are you tired of the
Saints doing it no absolutely they can
do as I was at the Bills game last year
where you guys were dancing yeah
Herschel yeah and I thought that was
going to be they think so you think that
celebration is the Saints thing
everybody else should stop yeah I
believe so
because it's crazy mo Claybourne got a
pick brush the coats yeah he ran it back
yeah and guys went over there and tried
to do the they did it I kind of like
raining you didn't do it I didn't do it
and my coach my coach left I mean you've
made a joke and said oh and your
individual but yeah who was messing with
me but at the same time I just didn't I
enjoyed it yeah I enjoyed that my
brother made a picnic but I just
couldn't I couldn't get into that
celebration because it's not mine it's
not I like this guy copyright
infringement yeah poser and you face Tom
Brady three times yeah what is it about
it do you have a play or an example that
shows how much he owns that position
honestly there was a play this last game
I try to jump to snap I honestly was
gonna as I call it short by the model
we're gonna jump over the lobby one jump
over the line I definitely was ops I
knew the play I knew was a run play and
I was I was honestly trying to get him
but he looked at me and I kind of looked
away and don't make eye contact
yeah then I looked at him and I looked I
looked at the clock it was like eight
then I'm like okay usually around the
around six to sit around six or seven
he's been snapping the ball I was head
of game as soon as six hit I take off he
sees me he holds it and then they get me
he was gonna he was gonna double he was
only double counting me cuz he saw that
he saw it I was he knew I was coming
alright he just does the little things
consistently and he takes advantage of
your mistakes he waits for you to make
make a mistake because he's not gonna
make a mistake
more than likely yeah just waiting for
you to be this way he's just waiting
that's awesome yeah
you're great but are great I'm looking
at your shirt this is something you
worked on with the airport missing in
football right now yeah is tackling and
we think that you have a lot of pent-up
anger and we want to take care of that
yeah we have a subpopulation might let's
do it my haters the Krenim hold the
ceiling game down we're tired of your
constant winning and your sustained
excellence and you get all the calls and
we're just done with it I hate you so
much for those who said I couldn't cover
groan you have a lot of frustration man
oh damn it look at that yeah he's got to
go to the blue tent now I'm sick of
being accessible all the time I'm sick
of walking around New York City with
everybody like this and they don't even
look at anybody anymore
new phone who dis this is to every
person in the Instagram comment section
with a big mouth god that feels so good
guys I get it
and I was a good one they're doing an
hour-long Phil Simms special what do you
think about it though we need to fix
this TV yeah that will leave any of the
stress most definitely man so damn good
see that's what people come on The Sims
and left go with the players show we are
here for you
damn you tell you what receivers are in
trouble because now he's loosened up and
ready to go overweight smashing stuff
with Jamal Adams bucket list he was
strong look very stronger the first time
he threw the printer the tile fell on
the ceiling yeah he's awesome he's the
best safety in football and that was a
lot of fun I'll say this that damn
patriot shot glass I threw that against
the wall and it didn't break you looked
at it like it was like had a haunted
spirit I feel like Bill Belichick built
the damn thing or something I was like
oh it's indestructible like the Patriots
yeah Jamal's gonna be in trouble now
that he's threatened the great Bill
Belichick uh they might have a new coach
for the Jets they're definitely gonna
have a new coach for the Packers and as
the gambling guy hello gambling guy I
have some odds here that I'm very
curious I'm gonna get your football mind
on we're not going to talk about the
Pete Carmichael's or the Eric be enemies
we're gonna start off first the gambling
favorite right two to one John Dee
filippo current OC of the Vikings should
he be the favorite in your mind no he
should not be I do think that John Dee
Filippo is a guy that has head coach in
his future it's his second year really
being an offensive coordinator at the
NFL level and I would also argue this
left go his base offense is very similar
to Mike McCarthy
it's West Coast base I think they need
some different ideas some different
ideology in that bill I got a guy for
you oh you got a guy number two you
gotta get to 25 Oh Josh McDaniels Oh
we'll see you the Patriots my first
question is after the Colts hired him
and then he walked away do you think the
Packers would take that risk I will say
this as much as respect I have for the
Colts and all that I do think this is a
little different job I mean last year
the Colts certainly are not the Green
Bay Packers as far as historic
franchises Andrew Luck in the shoulder
she was a big question mark played in
the year exactly right that quite right
so now you're going Green Bay it's
Titletown it's Vince Lombardi its frozen
tundra right it's one of the original
teams in the NFL and you feel like oh I
can go there and get off to a pretty
good start
they got a Rogers a quarterback yeah so
you're gonna feel good about that it's
probably the one I'd like to see the
most all right
we like offense for Aaron Rodgers we're
going to college for this big time
offense Oklahoma Lincoln Riley at ten to
one right does this make sense to you
could this be the offense that Aaron
needs to put up 40 points a game no I
don't really understand how this became
a hot topic I really don't I understand
he's a really good coach I've been
around like his command like his
schematics for college football for the
NFL level people would look at that and
go what's so special he's playing in the
big 12 where they play two or three
defenses the whole game the whole year
there's not a lot of good defensive
players in general I just think that
it's a little too early for me to say
Lincoln Riley to the NFL um so I have
someone that's better than Belichick
yeah okay I've looked at this list and
I'm on him for I always know when you're
like you're absolutely creative Vil
there isn't just office oh they're not
just defense oh they're not just special
teams they're one with every who you
gone I have somebody that is
world-renowned right Tony Dungy type of
vibe Wow I'd like to introduce you to
the next head coach of the Green Bay
Packers the Dalai Lama his holiness
how's this o'clock managed look at
Erin's smile
have you seen Erin smile like that in
the last year well no I think he's
smiling because he's going man this
guy's gonna be my new head coach and he
doesn't even know what this thing he's
holding is he doesn't know even how to
hold it but maybe that's what they need
in Green Bay Oh
maybe they've been doing the same thing
for so long they need someone that
doesn't know the thing that they've done
for so long I'm sure the Dalai Lama has
forward three years right two playoff
losses and a little weight he put on so
I had stress this job he's going hey
Wisconsin Post Gazette I've answered you
already we practice outdoors he's
turning into Patricia a Packers coaching
job it's really tough it is
what do you think I don't think so sorry
great guy I mean awesome I want a great
guy yeah yeah that's what they tell me
it's like telling me who's they huh I
don't know I just read it in the paper
the news what's up I'm tarik Cohen
running back for Chicago Bears and you
watch the Sims and let go babe
only a few Thursday Night Football games
left and honestly I'm tired of trying I
found Ali he's really good he's five in
two he got the Saints wrong but I'm
feeling better about this week I hope
Ali is
allez hey he's surprised to see me yeah
man i am i yeah let it out you know what
may I've never done this before I've
never come back to somebody that's lost
yes I know I know and you know what I'm
happy about okay I think that it Dallas
did what they were supposed to do yeah
they got a Drew Brees shook him up a
little bit and made it difficult Sims
told me to give you a message
screw you on the Oracle I believe it's
what he told me to tell you have to
swallow that this week yeah as
punishment though okay I'm giving you
Titans Jaguars we went from that
incredible Thursday night game to this
one where it's just trying not to be in
last place Titans are favored by four
and a half okay
break it down who you going with Titans
are favored by four and a half at home
at home Titans have historically had the
Jaguars number Jaguars new quarterback
scored six points and got a win
Titans came back and beat the Jets I
still think that the Titans four and a
half yes we'll pull it off at home I
agree with you at home this is one of
those toss-up games it's like they're
still fighting for the playoffs
yeah okay Titans sure yes
lock it in all right you're five and two
when I come back next week I want you to
be six legs and so I don't know about
five and three nope
what do you know Sims alley went with
the favorite yeah tracking he has a
tendency to pick favorite he's my guy he
did say that you're still the Oracle for
this week I really like you man I'm
gonna come visit you at some point say
hi I just want to give you a hard time
every time we have a show every other
NFL show I hear about still talks about
the Chiefs and they still talk about the
Chargers and we just want to be honest
with you guys it's probably gonna go
through New England when we look at the
Chiefs and we look at the Chargers we
look at the Steelers and the Texans and
all these teams in the playoffs the
Ravens right yeah of all those teams
right what is the best chance of going
into New England and beating the
Patriots I'm going with your team that
you pick for the Super Bowl the Houston
Texans
Wow nine in a row Texas yeah I think
that makes sense who picked you did oh
you did now you pick up a Green Bay but
so avoid that but either way the Houston
Texans I do look at it for two reasons
one we've seen coaches with familiarity
give Bill Belichick and Josh McDaniels
problems so for Bill O'Brien right yes
but okay and then the other thing I like
about them we've seen the formula to
beat the New England Patriots and Tom
Brady right the two Super Bowl losses
the AFC right the Giant Eagle right the
the Broncos and the Ravens who gave them
hard time they could get there with four
guys right
I think the Texans are a team to watch
out for would there be no what else and
that is a great way to beat the England
yeah a quarterback that Belichick can't
get hurt right yeah Shaun Watson's that
guy he is Wow yeah what a pic by I got a
man crush on the Texas you know they
players gonna say me no definitely not
on you sorry unfortunate for Sims peace
out homies I on the lef koe man we're
leaning forward because we want you to
know how much we care have a great day
[Music]
citizen left co the players show making
you feel better okay hey what's up
homies thanks for watching subscribe to
the be our YouTube channel man you're
such a millennial also while you're here
we have a lot of other videos check them
out and then what time does our show
come out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or
be square
he ruined it it was really close